Today is google developer program engineer Araki
is
Today we will introduce you to the action bar controller pad
Action Bar Compat is using Action Bar from android 2.1 onwards
It is compatible rally to be able to
It is equipped with android 3.0 or 4.0 or later
Action bar api will be available on older devices
At the time of new project creation if you use the latest android studio
The action bar console pad is built in to the existing project here
Let's think about how to incorporate and see how to use it
If you are using a grader, just add a line to the build. Gradel
Library can be added to the project
If you are not using sdk texts in the directory you installed
android support v 7 up this pad
Project as a library project
Please add to
Let's first look at how to change the resource file
When using the action bar controller pad, the theme of the activity is one of the three shown
Must be one
Theme Up Now Pad is a Dark Background Theme The Upcon Pad Light is a Bright Background
Theme up compatto light dark action bar on light background
It is an action bar
Specifically, where it is as above in android manifest xml
Change as you did
Be careful because it will be at-style rather than cut android colon style
Please give me
The previous example was a simple example, but you have already created a custom theme for the entire app
For example, let's look at the case where it looks like
There are two basic principles to match a custom theme to the action bar control pad
I will
The first is to specify one of the three themes we mentioned earlier as the parent theme
The second one has an android namespace for all attributes
It is to prepare two things which are not attached
Specifically, it looks like api Level 14 or later system standard
As attributes are available as above on files in v 14 folders android
Specify attribute with namespace
In the previous api level, the library uses the provided attributes
As it is necessary like below
Specify without namespace
Items such as buttons placed on the action bar can be added as a menu as usual
Be aware that action bar specific attributes are provided in the library
Need to use
The second line of code you're defining defines a new xml namespace
If it is pure up, the part may be any name but the action below
View live house
If you skip the namespace of attributes such as lucid action in android
Please try to use the space of this new sister
Next we will look at the code
Activities are not regular activity classes but action bar activities
Please inherit the class
This class contains action bar related methods in the normal activity class
There are several methods that have support in their names in a corresponding way
Sound create options as usual for buttons on the action bar
By using ef 8 the menu resource prepared earlier in the menu method
available
If you use the search b menu item menu item menu item
Instead of using the get action view, which is a method, now menu items
Use what is provided as a static method of class Pat
For fragments, provided by a nonion support library
Please use
When adding a menu item from fragment, in the create method
It should be set, and after calling like options menu true
Create options menu and note repair options menu
Override the method
In addition to the normal ui options attribute when using the split action bar
Need to add metadata elements within the activity element
Finally, I will introduce three other functions related to the action bar
When using the search view, use the class provided by the library
Need to use
However, the support library itself of action bar comp is api level 7
Set of search view classes as opposed to available from
Able info method is api level 8 or later
Please note that is not available
There is also a compatible version available for share action providers
As well
Instead of the standard android as a namespace for menu resources
Let's use what was defined in the application side
If you are in the code, create action menu and get action
When using a provider method
The menu items are now static as in the previous search view.
Please use the method
There is a compatible version of popupmenu class
The basic usage is the same as a regular popup menu
Action bar activity is also compatible with navigation drawer
there is
As you can see, the action bar draw will take a class called toggle in the layout
You can register as a listener
You can also display a progress bar in the action bar
The example you see is specifying feature in Bittermint Progress and the circle is
You will see a rotating loading animation
If you use feature progress instead, set support blogless method
You can set the degree of progress
The transition to the upper hierarchy added in android 4.1 can also use the compatible version
Ah
One more activity of seaweed activity
Specified in manifest file
As in the action bar of the split action view, to the activity element
Add standard attributes and metadata elements
It is an introduction of external tools
Action Bar Style Generator is an action bar on the web
It is a tool that can be customized
Resource file awareness can be downloaded by specifying the color of each part
If you specify up compatibility in the selection item of style compatibility
Action bar compatible and compatible style files are generated
I will
It is introduction of external library
You can update the list by scrolling down in the gmail app etc.
But Action Barpruet Refresh realizes that interface
It is a library
Here too, the action bar controller pad is supported
How is it? By all means using the action bar console pad android standard
Please try to create an application that conforms to the design guidelines of
I will